did you as a government really
prioritize dogs
over people to get them out of
afghanistan i think you can see that we
didn't do that because in two weeks we
pulled off and it was a joint effort for
an office home office mod the evacuation
of 15 000 people that's just in two
weeks that is the biggest evacuation and
living memory the only country that got
more people out was the united states
and it took an absolutely heroic and
herculean effort to achieve that under
incredibly difficult conditions didn't
doesn't mean that you didn't prioritize
dogs over people apparently uh the quote
the written statement that will be given
to the house uh to a house of commerce
committee later on is that
they received an instruction from the
prime minister to use considerable
capacity to get these dogs uh out of
afghanistan sorry it's just not accurate
we course didn't that's a lie we did not
put uh the welfare of animals above uh
individuals
and i think you can see that in the
facts of 15 000 people evacuated in just
two weeks as i said biggest effort
operation and living memory
and only the u.s got more out that's a
lie
that he said that i'm not accusing
anyone of lying i'm just correcting the
facts okay um he also went on to say
this young guy who was desk officer 25
years old said there were 75 to 100 000
please for help less than five percent
were helped
do you recognize those figures i i i
don't but what is certainly true
is that we had a lot of people rushing
to get out of afghanistan for all sorts
of reasons and i think it's right that
we had a process in place to check two
things one that we were helping those at
genuine risk of persecution or british
nationals or people who would work for
the british government and secondly
making sure
that we didn't allow anyone to come into
the uk who might present a threat to the
uk and it was important to have a
process to make those decisions swiftly
but also accurately so it was important
to
to in order to make sure that people
didn't come into the uk who perhaps
shouldn't be coming in that they were
left behind to be murdered
no that's not what i'm saying but i
think anyone would expect us to conduct
the basic checks the basic checks and
the real challenge in the evacuation uh
was the operational situation on the
ground so getting people to the airport
that was extremely difficult and
secondly verifying identity and of
course you've got to verify identity to
make sure you're helping those who are
genuinely most at risk and also at the
same time just checking we're not
through that generosity of spirit
letting anyone in that might harm the uk
but you accept that some of those who
have been left behind have been murdered
look i think it's an incredibly
difficult situation
we would have wanted a longer time
window
in order to
get out um everyone who was eligible but
even after the evacuation i saw this
myself
we were working to get flights out of
kabul with qatar we were working with
regional partners to make sure that we
could take british nationals and those
that we had said that we would take we
did everything we could and again i say
come back to the point fifteen thousand
people evacuated in two weeks uh
never been done before certainly not in
my living memory and only the united
states got more people out i think
i think that was actually a record that
those involved particularly those
working on the ground should be proud of
so a longer timeline could have saved
lives we've always said that we're up
against this timeline
that a combination of the u.s uh
deadline
and the taliban's approach to it that
we're working to an expedited deadline
and and look that put pressure on the
evacuation plan but we've been planning
for this uh since well before since
january
and indeed again in april we changed the
travel advice uh the those schemes like
the app scheme were being set up uh but
of course if we'd have had extra time we
would have um uh prolonged that
well
and as a result of the change you've got
to adapt to the changing situation on
the ground the taliban takeover and at
that point
we continued to work with our partners
qatar to get further flights with
british nationals and others that worked
for us out we also worked with the
partners on the borders both in the
uzbekistan
pakistan we did everything we could but
you have to have some form of process
again otherwise you're not going to be
letting in those who are most at need of
your help and also i think the public
and people watching this would expect us
to check that we don't have anyone
coming into the uk who pose a threat to
us it's important that i put some more
of these allegations that will uh be
will develop during the course of the
day to you then you get an opportunity
to reply um he also said the
whistleblowers will call him um accused
you of sending back information that had
been sent to you because it was about
people that you wanted to get out of
afghanistan because you wanted it better
presented in a spreadsheet
that's not quite right but what is
absolutely true to say with the volume
of applications we were considering we
wanted to make sure we had the basic
facts in order to make clear decisions i
think the charge that was leveled as it
took several hours to make these
decisions not weeks
not days even several hours i think it's
right to take uh the time and it was
something that i was doing with the home
secretary the defense secretary
depending on the category case to make
sure that we're helping those who are
eligible those that really needed our
help those that were british nationals
and not allowing in those that might
threaten the country he says that people
died because you wanted a spreadsheet
it's just not correct
okay
um did you and the pm mislead parliament
by
falsely saying the emails had been read
when they hadn't by ticking them as read
when they hadn't been
so every email that was ticked as read
and uh had been read by somebody who
could perhaps have made a difference
well i can't vouch for every
action of every official in relation to
every email but certainly uh i i've
never asked for uh emails to be ticked
as read that weren't read okay uh he
also went on to say that at times the
only person dealing with the desperate
emails were junior officials and on one
occasion he was the only person that was
working on these emails well we had a
thousand people from the in the foreign
office alone uh looking at these and of
course the foreign office was the
repository for applications uh for arab
uh for the special cases as well as for
questions of british nationality
so it was a a challenge but we had
across whitehall teams a thousand
foreign office officials working
on the evacuation a whole range of home
office people and mod people working on
them
and of course it's not just a question
of answering the emails it's when they
can and there are many duplicated claims
it's making sure that you have a process
that can swiftly but accurately decide
those claims that was where the focus
was he talks about the culture at the
foreign office and the fact that people
would only work their set hours of eight
hours others were working from home and
as a result junior officials were being
left to make life or death decisions
i i i don't accept that characterization
would and i know that's not true but i
know officials are going to be giving
evidence to the foreign affairs
committee later on but i regularly
checked that we were properly resourced
but the challenge of course with all of
these things was the verification of the
facts on the ground so if you have a lot
of undocumented people coming forward
and saying either they're a british
national or that they're uh qualified
with special cases scheme you've got to
find a process which can clarify the
facts the basic facts in order to make
an informed decision if you'd had more
staff working more hours you could have
done that quicker and potentially save
lives well no next exactly that point i
think the the inherent challenge of
getting factual questions in relation to
undocumented people applying for the
three different schemes that were uh
available i i i you know that is
inherent i don't think having extra
staff in london would have uh
particularly made that easier the
challenge was
deciphering the facts on the ground as
well as the second operational challenge
which was making sure we could get to
the airport in kabul uh safe passage
given the very difficult conditions
there to that end apparently um one
computer for eight soldiers on the
ground they all had to use it to try to
uh verify facts in order to get people
to the airport do you recognize that i
know that would be a
that would have been an issue for the
mod but uh all i can tell you if that
was the case how do you feel about that
i'm trying to answer the questions and
the facts that as as i know them but all
i'd say is yeah but one computer eight
soldiers when you're trying to get tens
of thousands of people out in a very
well the soldiers aren't
are primarily there to be behind
a computer but there were mod home
office officials foreign office staff
but the point i would make is that
actually the troops on the ground did an
incredible job but so did the other back
up
officials whether they were home office
nationality or border staff and of
course the foreign office led by lori
bristow do you recognize the allegation
that at times there was just one junior
official on the desk trying to process
all of these emails no i don't i mean
and if that were to be the case how
would you feel well again i don't answer
hypothetical questions what i know is
that i i mean i certainly regularly
checked with nigel casey and we're the
the relevant director of the team who
did a brilliant job in my view um and
the officials that we were properly
resourced as i said i think you're
confident that you were i think i think
uh if i may say so that the and i
understand why if you're a relatively
junior desk officer it would have felt
like you're under a lot of pressure the
inherent challenge that we had was the
situation on the ground
in kabul the challenge of deciphering
and working out who was eligible who was
not and then getting from the them to
the airport safely we got fifteen
thousand people out um and i think that
others stayed behind and died well and
and this is true for i think for all of
the western countries that were there we
were right it doesn't it doesn't and uh
but but it does show you that we did
everything we could because we haven't
seen an evacuation like that in living
memory and no other country i mean the
us is the only other country and they
were there on a greater scale that got
more people out okay there is going to
be an investigation it was launched in
august an internal inquiry when will we
see the results of that
the the internal inquiry yeah into what
happened uh yeah his evidence was so
serious apparently that an entire
internal inquiry was launched in august
we haven't seen the results of that year
well that's uh that's something that the
following the deputy prime minister yes
but of course and we've got a team
effort here and i'm sure the foreign
office will uh give the full timeline
when they give evidence to the foreign
affairs select committee later on today
okay you lost your job as a result of
what happened
on a reflection do you think that's fair
i don't think that's true um and i know
i did everything i possibly could and
again i point to the facts that we uh
and not just the fifteen thousand in
that two weeks we we secured the safe
passage of seventeen thousand people if
you take the period uh from april which
shows you that we've been planning uh
since well before
the the august evacuation and the
taliban take over why do you think you
lost your job
well uh those are decisions for the
prime minister but i um
i'm pretty confident from what he said
to me that it wasn't in relation to
afghanistan
and of course today then potentially you
know
we may be looking at that again do you
think
no
but uh these aren't my calls i serve at
the pleasure of the prime minister okay
talk to me uh before i let you go
because i know that we are almost out of
time
um talk to me about what on earth
happened at this party that we keep
hearing about at number 10. uh on sunday
you said that police don't normally
quoting you don't normally look back and
investigate things that have taken place
a year ago yesterday we had the policing
minister on the program he said we
should be investigating anything that is
a historic crime to them the police
should be investigating that where are
we today well so my quote was directly
from what the metropolitan police said
this is a matter for them they said that
in relation to covid regulations they
wouldn't routinely investigate a
retrospective breaches so i was simply
uh pointing to what the police
themselves have said number ten have
been very clear there was no party
there's been no breach of the rules and
frankly uh i appreciate i've asked this
answer the questions from you i answer
questions on sunday which i'm very happy
to do but i don't have anything further
to add it's pretty categorical yeah i
understand that deputy prime minister
final question on it though before i let
you go if i may and that is that we're
still talking about it you know um 10
days in
why doesn't why doesn't the prime
minister or you yeah all the police in
and say have a look at this and then we
can say yeah it's you know our hands are
clean it's for the police to decide what
they do and the
prime minister and number the police
could ask the prime minister could ask
the police to look at it well
to be honest with you it's for the
police they've already had uh the the
facts sent to them they've already had
they've well we've seen two labour mps
ask um for it and they've made clear in
the way but it's ultimately a matter for
the police and just on the fundamental
point number 10 have been very clear
there was no party and there were no
rules breached okay it's good to talk to
you good to talk to you like thank you
very much